I'd like to thank you for leaving crazy
person out of the description so I
thought I try to think what is the most
useful thing that I could what could I
say like that could actually helpful or
useful to you in the future
and I thought perhaps tell the story of
how I sort of came to be here how did
some of these things happen and and
maybe there's some lessons there because
I often find myself wondering how did
this happen
so when I was young I I I didn't really
know what I was going to do we're not
when I got older people kept asking me
and and but but then eventually I
thought the idea of inventing things
would be would be really cool and the
reason I thought that was because I read
a quote from Odyssey clock which said
that a sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic and and
that's really true if you think if you
go back say 300 years the things that we
take for granted today would be you'd be
burned at the stake for you know being
able to fly that's crazy
being able to see over long distances
being able to communicate having
effectively with the internet a a group
mind of sorts and having access to all
the world's information instantly from
almost anywhere in the earth this is the
stuff that that really would be magic it
would be considered magic in times past
in fact I think it actually goes beyond
that because there are many things that
we take for granted today that weren't
even imagined in times past they weren't
even in the realm of magic so it
actually goes goes beyond that so I
thought well you know if if I can do
some of those things basically if I can
advanced technology then that that's
like magic and I would be really cool
and
the the I also had sort of a slight
existential crisis because I was trying
to figure out what does it all mean like
what's the purpose of things and I came
to the conclusion that if we can advance
the the knowledge of the world if we can
do things that expand the scope and and
scale of consciousness then we're better
able to ask the right questions and
become more enlightened and and that's
really the only way forward so so it's
like I studied physics and business
because I figured in order to do a lot
of these things you need to know how the
universe works and you need to know how
how how the economy works and you also
need to built bringing a lot of people
together to work with you to create
something because it's very difficult to
do something as as individual if it's if
it's a significant technology so I
originally came out to California to try
to figure out how to improve the energy
density of electric vehicles basically
to try to figure out if there was an
advanced capacitor that could serve as
an alternative to batteries and that was
in 95 and that's also when the internet
started to happen and and it I I thought
well I can either pursue this tech this
technology where success maybe may not
be one of the possible outcomes which is
always tricky or participate in the
internet and and be part of it so I
decided to drop out now fortunately
we're past graduation so I can't be
accused of recommending that to you
and so it's a did some internet stuff
you know did a few things here and there
what one of which was PayPal and and
maybe it's helpful to say one of the
things that was important than in the
creation of PayPal was which was kind of
how it started because initially the
initial thought was with PayPal was to
create an agglomeration of financial
services so if you have one place where
all your financial services needs would
be seamlessly integrated and and work
smoothly and then we had like a little
feature which was to do email payments
and whenever we'd show that show the
system off to someone would show the
hard part which was the UM the
agglomeration of financial services
which was quite difficult to put
together nobody was interested then we'd
show people email payments which was
actually quite easy and everybody was
interested so this is a I think it's
important to take feedback from your
environment you know it's it you want to
be as closed-loop as possible and so we
focused on email payments and really try
to make that work and that's what really
got things to take off but if we hadn't
if we hadn't responded to what people
said then we probably would not have
been successful so it's important to
look for things like that and and focus
on them when when you when you see them
and you're correct your your prior
assumptions and then the it going from
PayPal
I thought well what are some of the the
other problems that are likely to most
affect the future of humanity
it really wasn't from the perspective of
what what's the rank or did best way to
to make money which which is which is
okay but it was really what I think is
going to most affect the future humanity
so the I think the biggest terrestrial
problem we've got is sustainable energy
but the production and consumption of
energy in a sustainable manner
if we don't solve that the century is
the century where we're in deep trouble
and then yeah the other one being the
extension of life beyond Earth to make
life multiplanetary so that's that
that's that's the basis for that the
latter is the basis force for SpaceX and
the former is the basis for Tesla and
SolarCity and and when I started SpaceX
I initially I thought that well is
there's no way one could possibly start
a rocket company
I wasn't that crazy but but then I
thought well what is a way to increase
NASA's budget that was actually my
initial goal so I thought well if we do
a low-cost mission to Mars and they
called Mars oasis which would land seeds
with with dehydrate would receive some
dehydrated nutrient gel and you hydrate
them upon landing and then you'd have
this great sort of money shot of green
plants on a red background and the the
public tends to respond to presidents
and superlatives and this would be the
first life on Mars the farthest that
life's ever traveled as far as we know
and and I thought well that that would
get people really excited and and and
therefore increased at NASA's budget so
so obviously the the financial outcome
from such a mission would probably be
zero so anything better than that was on
the upside
so I actually went to I went to Russia
three times to look at buying
refurbished ICBM
because that was the best deal and I can
tell you it was very weird going there
in 2000 late 2001 2002 going to the
Russian rocket forces and saying I'd
like to buy two of your biggest rockets
but you can keep the nuke that's a lot
more and this that was ten years ago I
guess
they that I think they they thought I
was crazy but but I did have money so
that was that was okay
and after making several trips to to
Russia
I came conclusion that that actually my
initial impression was was wrong about
that because my initial thought was well
that that there's not enough will to
explore and expand beyond Earth and have
a Mars base and that kind of thing but I
can't cushion that that that was wrong
in fact there's plenty of will
particularly in the United States
because the United States is a nation of
explorers the people who came here from
from other parts of the world and I
think in the United States really a just
a distillation of the spirit of human
exploration so but but if people think
it's impossible then or it's going to
completely break the federal budget then
they're not going to do it so after my
third trip I said okay well what we
really need to do here is try to solve
the space transport problem and and
started SpaceX and this this was against
the advice of pretty much everyone I
talked to what one friend made me sit
down and watch a bunch of videos rockets
blowing up
let me tell you he wasn't far wrong
think it was it was tough going there in
the beginning because I'd never built
anything physical I mean I'd both like
little model rockets as a kid and that
kind of thing but I never had a company
that built in any physical setting I
figure out how to how to do all these
things and and bring together the right
team of people and and and so we we did
all that and and then failed three times
it was tough tough going because
thinking about a rocket is that the
passing grade is a hundred percent and
you don't get to actually test the
rocket in the real environment that is
going to be in so I think so the best
analogy for for rocket engineering is
it's like if you want to create a really
complicated but a software you can't run
the software as an integrated whole and
you can't run it on the computer it's
intended to run on but the first time
you put it all together and write it on
that computer it must run with no bugs
that's that's basically the essence of
it so we missed the mark there that the
first launch I was picking up bits of
rocket near the new launch scientist but
sad and but we learned with with each
success of flight and and were able to
with eventually with the fourth flight
in 2008 reach orbit and that was also
with the last bit of money that we had
so they thank goodness that that
happened it I think they're saying is
both times the charm
so that's we got the Falcon went orbit
and then began to scale that up to to
the Falcon 9 which is about an order of
magnitude more thrust it's a around a
million pounds of thrust and we managed
to get that to orbit and then developed
Dragon spacecraft which recently was
able to dock and return to Earth from
the space station that was thanks I was
a white knuckled event so yeah it's a
huge relief
slow can't quite believe it actually
happened but but there's a lot more that
must happen beyond this in order for
humanity to become a spacefaring
civilization ultimately a multi-planet
species and that's something I think
it's it's it's vitally important and and
I hope that that some of you will
participate in that either at SpaceX or
at other companies because it's just
really one of the most important things
for the preservation and extension of
consciousness and it's worth noting as
I'm sure people are aware that the earth
has been around for four billion years
and Britta's civilization at least in
terms of having writing has been around
for ten thousand years and that's being
generous so it's it's really it's
somewhat of a tenuous existence that
that civilization and and consciousness
as we know it has has been on earth and
I think I'm actually I'm actually fairly
optimistic about the future of Earth so
I don't want to I don't want to sort of
people to have the wrong impression that
I think we're all about to die I think I
think well I think things will most
likely be okay for a look for a long
time on earth but not not for sure but
most likely
but even if it's if it's sort of 99%
likely one a 1% chance it's still it's
little worth spending a fair bit of
effort to ensure that we have we've
backed up the biosphere in a planetary
redundancy if you will and and so I
think I think it's really really quite
important and in order to that there's a
breakthrough that needs to occur which
is to create a rapidly and completely
reusable transport system to Mars which
which is one of those things that's
right on the borderline of impossible
but that's sort of the thing that we're
we're going to try to achieve there with
with with SpaceX and then on the on the
on the Tesla front the goal with Tesla
was really to try to show that what
electric cars can do because people had
the wrong impression we had to change
people's perception of an electric
vehicle because they used to think of it
as something that was slow and ugly and
had low range and like a golf cart and
work so that's why we created the Tesla
Roadster to show that you can be fast
attractive and and long range and and
it's amazing how even though you can
show that something works on paper you
know and the calculations are very clear
until you actually have the physical
object and they can they can drive it it
doesn't really sink in for people and so
that that I think is is something worth
learning if you're going to create a
company the first thing you should try
to do is create a working prototype
you're everything everything looks great
on PowerPoint okay you can make anything
work on PowerPoint but if you have an
actual demonstration article even if
it's in primitive form that's much much
more effective for convincing people so
so we made the Tesla Roadster and now
we're coming out soon with the Model S
which is a four-door sedan because after
we made the Tesla Roadster people said
oh sure sure we always knew you could
make a car like that it's an expensive
car and it's low volume and it's small
and all that but you couldn't make a
real car like
fine you're gonna make that too so that
that's coming out soon and yeah so that
that's that that's that's the I think
the the word where things are and and
and hopefully that there are some
lessons to be to be drawn there but I I
think the overarching point I want to
make is that you guys are the magicians
of the 21st century you know don't like
anything hold you back
imagination is the limit and go out
there and create some magic thank you